so let's go e4 okay so this guy plays
the french which we haven't really faced
much
uh there's a couple of good options
against the french that i recommend to
intermediate players
one of them is called the reside
variation
where i just talk about the lines that
we can play and our opponent resigns
that's a fantastic line
[Music]
i was gonna say knight c3 here is a good
line
uh this is like the topical variation of
the french there is also e5 which is
called the advance
by the way the french if anybody's
curious
why is the french called the french the
first person to have ever played the
french
let me see
the first person to have ever played the
french
was well it was cochrane
it was that same guy who developed the
cochrane gambit
okay so the city of paris
played the french in 1834 in a game
against the city of london
and that was very common in the 19th
century the two cities
for to play a game and they would submit
the moves by telegram
uh but but the city of paris is not the
first to play the french
okay 1751 very strong player
let's hope he doesn't abort okay let's
go e4 e5
we've been playing the sicilian a lot
recently but let's let's go back to e5
for a second
okay so let's see if okay he plays in
italian so my favorite move here is
bishop to c5
knight f6 and either okay so d4
is one of the main moves this is the the
old main line bishop before
check this is all very normal
knight takes c4 and now d5 okay so
this this line i'm playing this fast
because this is all theoretical line i
actually don't remember it
so i could i could get in trouble here
quite quickly let me see if i can
remember
what we're supposed to do here i think
we're supposed to drop the bishop back
to f6
he goes rookie one and then we cancel i
think
uh there is a way here for black to get
an advantage this is called the miller
counter gambit
okay but this is not the right move i'm
pretty sure because now
i think we can just take back on c6 and
can somebody explain to me perhaps
why is it that after b takes c6 rookie
one we don't lose our knight
what move are we gonna have after that
yeah we're gonna have d5 and we're going
to simultaneously attack the bishop and
defend the knight
so i think this move dc is already a
mistake i think he had to play rookie
one
and that leads to a theoretical line so
now we're up two pawn we're up two pawns
and it just doesn't seem like he's got
much to show for them
uh because we're gonna play d5 okay
d5 baby is right and i think he's
recognized it
i did not lose the knight remember that
i took his knight
and he didn't recapture back and he took
my knight but only after
he accepted the loss of his now in this
position
i think almost everybody would be
inclined to play bishop f5 but we don't
have to do that and again this is
something that i want to make very clear
we are up two pawns and we have a set of
priorities and our top priority
is to remove our king from the line of
fire of the rook
if that means we sacrifice one of our
extra pawns to do that
so be it he doesn't even take it
okay now we can safely play bishop f5 to
buttress the knight
that's totally fine then we could deploy
our queen to d7 in the event of we could
have also oh we could have just taken
the pawn but there's no need for
that kind of greediness so
and someone's getting a big raid after
this game
okay queens of c2 so how do we go about
doing this we can well he's attacking
the pawn
we can protect it in several ways the
move i like is c5 let's just push the
spawn forward
the knight defends the pawn and if he
takes on e4 with a bishop
well then we can just recapture with our
bishop and we potentially threaten to
[ __ ] his pawn structure with bishop
takes b2
hopefully this is making sense so far he
goes 95
what should we do here what moves come
to mind does anybody want to suggest
perhaps
a way let's say to dislodge this knight
from e5 how do we get it out of there
while deploying another one of our
pieces
moves like rookier are the glue moves
they're the moves that
make our position tick he counter
attacks our knight but
trades are good for us thank you silent
menace 13 for the prime
trades are good for us because we're the
ones up two puns we're up three puns
and now we're going to be up more than
three pounds we're going to be up a
piece after we make what move
what move now wins a very simple fork
queen to d4 remember he's weakened the
diagonal in front of his king by
as soon as f3 is played you must pay
attention
sorry to this diagonal because that
diagonal is the key to the kingdom in
many cases
now we take another piece queen e7 is
right
and the game is over we're up a piece
we're up three pawns and
we have total domination let's get the
rook involved through d8 never forget to
involve your pieces when you're up
material
we have many ways to win this uh let's
go g6 to create some luft for our king
some air let's go f5 to defend our
bishop
and now we're going to go queen to d to
force the queen trade
or uh take a bunch of his pawns or
deliver checkmate depends on what he
decides to do
um yeah we're just going to trade queens
that's the easiest
and how do we win this position i've
talked about this many times what you
want to do is identify
where you can create a past pawn and
then create it he's basically creating
it for us
uh we can also what i was preparing is
the move c3
getting rid of one of our doubled pawns
that the other one is going to be passed
and uh this is just going to be a
winning position for black
okay let's go c3 well we got 4481
viewers that's ridiculous
and now well we can push our pawn but
what's the simplest move here instead of
pushing our pawn
what can we do just to eliminate any
possibility
of counter play by white we can
what that really means is we need to
look for ways to trade rooks
we can do that by playing rook to c2
that's the simplest
we're just gonna have an extra bishop
and two past pawns that cannot be
stopped
so the game is over we can resign that's
also that's always possible
yeah nice nice nice okay
this is over and uh that was simple
because our opponent messed up
the opening but
oh my lands
damn girl jab jam with 25
gifted subs oh my
lance this is ridiculous
ridiculous that is a huge number right
there we are almost at 36
30 700. this is unbelievable thank you
jam jam for another 25 gifted subs
crazy absolutely crazy stuff
and uh this is ridiculous
enjoy guys thank you telemamma for the
prime
it's like i'm obligated to keep playing
well i don't know what to say and he
finally resigns
um yeah i mean
this is uh this is unbelievable thank
you jack star and we got more subs we
got jackster a
one aotn with a prime
okay okay i'll i'll consider it just
give me a sec
holy smokes okay now i gotta play one
because we got yazizy gifting 10 subs
this is the most generosity i've ever
seen and it's been going on like this
for days and days and days
he's back he's back with 10 gifted oh my
lance
this is remarkable ladies and gentlemen
happy thanksgiving indeed uh
thank you yazizy for the 10 gifted
there is always a gifting battle going
on 36.80
and wanje with the prime jam jam gifting
to ignore 27.
i can't keep up with this we are 18 away
from 2700
3700 this is ridiculous okay
um let's see
yeah you guys are awesome is
understating it tremendously
um how do you feel after all this no i'm
fine
zam 13 ho 10 more
it doesn't even end
oh my god zan13 with 10 subs oh my
god
oh i can this is not happening right now
this is not happening right this is not
happening right
i need to keep my voice down because
this is
this is illegal montana chess with a
hundred
hundred gifted subs and then proffer
with twenty
this is actually the most progress thing
ever we got four thousand people
watching
insaneness happened insanity
montana chess has previously supported
me tremendously
with doughnuts yeah zazie we got we got
a sub from urca 33
zaizzy with 10 again oh my god i'm not
even analyzing
holy smokes oh chuck
cheese curl of five
four thousand here we come
when i hit 3 000 i thought that was
ridiculous what is
this what is this
montana chess just gifted a hundred subs
followed by 20 followed by 5g mario 2
pandora
with a prime shush about our money
laundering magnolia
with the gift it's up to wowzer78 over
3700
i can't concentrate this is ridiculous
e-dog 3650 gifting three subs to the
community
oh my god i'm just sitting back and
watching this happen as gem jam gifting
10 months oh my god
are you serious ladies and gentlemen
it just keeps on going
i guess the speed run was a good
decision 38-44 well-spoken oc lot with a
sub
yeah we've got and rob easy-e
with the prime
wow keep threatening to leave
min with a thousand bits he says you
think it's over girl
yeah this is amazing blind win nine
wow these are indeedy car numbers
uh these are incredible numbers
um 38.47
yeah keep going unbelievable
excuse me
well thanks i've never seen something
like this i mean it's like one night
after another
um oh definitely
okay uh all right let's go
let's keep playing we gotta keep playing
so this game really quickly
just uh this line that he played this is
called the miller counter gambit
and the idea is that he sacrifices a
piece but he tries to oh the
board is frozen sorry yeah the board is
frozen my bad my bad
there we go and we got bc crispy with
five gifted
holy smokes it doesn't even end there
and the key mistake that he made was
that he basically took the wrong knight
he should have gone
he should have gone after the e4 knight
with rook to e1
500 bits from snap boy and a hundred
bits from choir pm
and uh he should have taken this knight
so that it would be harder for us to
develop our bishop but by taking dc
he's allowed us to go d5 now we're two
pawns up our knight is defended
and uh and our bishop has excellent
prospects
so he played a little bit too fast and
after this
the key move is just a castle right we
tuck our king away
we don't let him exploit it and now we
go c5
chasing the knight away very simple
moves and then we win everything with
queen d4 check
yeah 100 4 000 subs i can't even believe
we're uttering those
words we're playing a guy who is 1641
acos she's robles let's go e5 again
and let's go with a classical
okay um let me disable the alerts for a
second
oh five thousand bits oh my lands
what is this another bomb i can't even
keep up with this
five thousand bits from jam let's go
knight f6 this is the main line of the
rye lopez
it should be familiar to most people um
these are just the main moves we're
developing our pieces the normal squares
and at this point he's threatening to
capture our knight
and capture on e5 so the time has come
for us
to remove the bishop from its post on a4
now we need to open up our own bishop
and so we play the move d6 to support
the center
and open up the bishop this is still
well within the range of the main line
of the rye lopez
thank you the giovanni 95 for the tier
one i appreciate it
now we castle and the main move here is
h3
so he plays d3 which which is a move
it's not the most
active mode but it is a move and
um and and and there's many ways for
black here to
develop my pieces right we can develop
this bishop to g4
we can well bishop g4 isn't as good as
it seems
i'm gonna play this move even though
it's not as good as it seems and after
the game
i'm going to explain why bishop g4 maybe
he'll show us
now i'm gonna go knight to well no
actually let's go
what should we do here should we do
let's get this bishop out of this
annoying little square on b3 we're gonna
go knight a5
we're going to expand on the queen side
with c5 it's very typical idea
now if he knows what he's doing we're
going to bring our knight back into the
game he'll get his knight to g3
and that's exactly why the pin isn't as
effective here
he played this perfectly he's forcing
our bishop back and we could have put a
bishop there in the first place
so we wasted a couple of time you know
he's playing this incredibly well d4 is
good
now we're going to take and the other
problem that we're encountering here
is that he's threatening a fork with d5
so
we're gonna have to take on d4 but now
what we're left with
is a not sure i like this time
consumption but
what we're left with is a weak pawn on
d6 a giovanni 95 with five gifted subs
so what do we need to do in this
position what we need to do in this
position
is activate the bishop on e7 it's
currently kind of passive
and so we'll need to put it on f6 but to
do that we need to move the knight away
from d7 thank you the giovanni 95 it
just keeps going and going
uh this is incredible stuff here okay so
he goes knight d5
let's get rid of that knight that was an
annoying night let's get rid of it
and now we can put our bishop on a very
nice square on a very nice diagonal
yeah gem jam is indeed the greatest ever
g6 okay blunting
his influence over the diagonal
obviously he was threatening checkmate
oh thank sorry ac7iomin now this knight
on d7
where can we put it where should it
where does it belong
where does this knife belong
it belongs either on c5 or it belongs on
e5 either of those two squares are fine
and when you have a situation like this
where you have two possible moves you're
not sure which one to make
it often makes sense to make a third
move something a little bit more
flexible
so that we can only develop our knight
when we're absolutely sure
of where we want to put it that's why
i'm going to play the move rook to c8
deploying our rook to an open file
because maybe i want to put the knight
on e5 maybe i want to put it on c5
i don't know uh it depends on what he's
going to do
so that's why we're going to hold off on
that decision for
a second okay
by the way queen a5 also something to
point out here which would fork his
his rook and his pawn on a2 that's
another possibility
in the future uh
yeah we wanted you want to be flexible
and trust you don't want to put all of
your cards on the table in one go
yeah 95 knight c4 is the idea okay so
now
it's definitely time for a little for
guruski attacking the rook attacking the
pawn
using our queen and uh this is uh
this is just starting to collapse for
him now look at how our pieces are
positioned i still haven't moved my
knife from d7 because i haven't needed
to you know there's
there's been no need to do that uh
instead
and i just got my queen trapped i just
got i
could have gotten my queen trap but that
was not so simple because of 95 that
would that would have been pretty close
okay what do we do how do we play
we'll talk about that after the game he
failed to spot a very big chance here
what should now what i'm seeing whoa
oh my goodness
what this is this is
unbelievable unbelievable
41 from polar bear bc
as i play 95 this was the moment for it
and we've got him tied up but look at
this man go
are we at 3 900 we are
this is actually legendary and i don't
know what to say
this is legendary
tonight might be the night this is
incredible we're going to go rook to c3
getting his queen dislodging it from its
attack over the rook look at how all of
our pieces are
operating at their full capacity
doubling now on the c file we're going
to go after this pawn on d5
what's our sub count now 3900 board has
been frozen my bad guys sorry sorry
sorry sorry
i know and that's a glitch that i need
to fix
uh that's an obs glitch
my apologies for that so we're just
gonna bring our queen back
now he's gone rook to c1 he's gone rook
to c1 what should we do here
how do we exploit the drawback of that
previous move very simple
solution we don't need to trade see this
is where people go wrong they're like
okay i need to trade rooks
you don't need to do anything this rook
is perfectly well protected so we can
just take the pawn
this might be a record of some sort
we're at 39
i mean i don't know what to say now we
can take the rook of course if he takes
our queen then we take his
we don't want to allow the queen to come
to c8
so let's go queen c4 a trade is in our
favor because we're up two pounds that
end game is going to be completely
winning
uh that end game is going to be
completely winning and so he resigns
that's a good resignation
uh and that was a pretty simple game
with one exception i think i made a key
blunder
that could have been exploited by him
let's go straight to that moment now
as i've explained previously
as i've explained previously
how should you judge a pin the way that
you should judge a pin
is if a the pinned piece right the
knight on f3 is defended by a pawn
then by definition the pin is going to
be less scary
if this knight was not defended by a
pawn the pen would be more scary so you
shouldn't
rush to always assume the best square
for a piece
is somewhere where it pins an opposing
piece
so i would have considered putting this
bishop on e6 to blunt the influence of
the bishop on v3
and uh what ended up happening is that
he attacked our bishop
and if you if we had dropped it to h5
we would have potentially allowed the
knight to get into this very very nasty
square on f5
and that would have been followed for
example with bishop to g5
so it's okay we got our bishop back to
e6 but now he's struck with d4
so what were we talking about here
before i got rudely interrupted well i
cried for four thousand
i'm not a big crier um that's just one
thing i'm just not big on
so we activated the knight then the
bishop the one moment i wanted to focus
on in this game
i very sloppily grabbed the pawn on a2
and ladies and gentlemen the move bishop
b3
would have well actually oh there's a
way out
this oh this is cool this would have
trapped the queen
the queen has nowhere to go if i take
the rook that's defended
but black has a way to counter-attack
white's queen and i think black is still
in good shape here
can somebody spot yeah we are 75 away i
mean this is
unbelievable uh the lack of support in
this
just what should we do here so there's a
couple of ways to go about attacking
white's queen
rook to c3 is one and knight to e5 is
the other
i've talked about the situation several
times the situation where
both queens are hanging what should you
be looking for when both queens are
hanging
what you should be looking for are
desperado sacrifices first of all
this knight on e5 do you see that
white's making contact with that
so why can't capture it okay and
we're back in the same situation and now
we're a piece down so this is no good
rook to c3 may seem to run into the same
exact problem right queen
queen takes c3 but if you calculate a
little bit further
we can actually take the queen and then
take the rook on e1 so if we just
specifically calculate the line
uh this works you can also take the rook
on b1 by the way
so either option works and so rook c3
was the saving grace
uh that would have allowed me to save
the queen i didn't actually see bishop
b3 though
well i did see it but i didn't notice
that it that it traps the queen
so um so so this was a lucky escape
isn't that bishop trapped in the
variation what if queen c2 or queen c2
just drops the bishop to the queen
drops the queen to the bishop how does
my bishop escape a couple of people are
asking
isn't the bishop traptor well how does
when actually trap the bishop
it's not easy to trap the bishop um
if 95 rookie five yeah is that fightable
so if you go
here uh this is fightable you have two
rooks for a queen and a piece
which is a pretty significant material
advantage for the queen and the piece
but uh you could fight this i mean you
could try to double rooks on the c
file you could try to double rooks on
the c file and you could try to
to infiltrate that way uh and
and and by by definitely i would not
suggest anyone resign here i would i
would play this myself
uh bishop h6 does not want an exchange
there so if you go
here and then you go bishop h6 i saw
this you attack the rook and attack the
bishop but you can move the rook to e8
and simultaneously defend the bishop on
e1
and and then the bishop could could
saunter over to g7
and evacuate itself and remember that
black is also up upon
okay one second please yeah i can't
believe this viewership is ridiculous
huh okay um
let's play one more i'm feeling lucky
today
i wonder why does anybody have any
questions and by the way the way that
the game ended was pretty uneventful i
mean
he he he managed to sort of stabilize
but because of the tremendous disparity
in peace activity and the fact that
we're up upon
why its position simply collapses okay
um let's go
let us go okay
let's go e4 so we've been playing e4
you know and he plays the scandinavian
okay so scandinavian
by our opponent which is not an opening
that i recommend
to intermediate players now that doesn't
mean it's a bad opening it's and
after the game i'll talk a little bit
about why it's actually not a bad
opening
but um let me just make a note of this
so of course
the the main drawback of the scandi just
visually speaking is that
black has only developed his queen and
we are not only developing our pieces
but we are also occupying the center so
it seems clear that white should be
better here but
wow so he's also wasting time moving the
same piece
two squares what should we do here with
white
what should we do here with white how do
we get rid of this pin the spin is kind
of annoying
i mentioned that it's not too dangerous
but uh if we wanted to develop with an
eye toward
defending against the pen we would just
go bishop e2 a lot of people don't like
making this move a lot of people look at
this move and say yeah the bishop is
passive
but it's okay not every one of your
pieces needs to be
conquering uh you know the fringes of
the roman empire it's okay to have a
single piece on e2
and it's okay to just castle and play
chill
now we have a chance now to capitalize
on the fact that this knight is no
longer pinned where can we put this
knight
where can we put this knight in order to
exert some pressure on black's position
absolutely let's centralize it i love
centralizing my knights
uh that sounds weird but okay i like
centralizing my knights
and uh we're slightly better here our
opponent is playing this quite well
now we need to think about where we want
to put this bishop we can put it on d2
to pressure that queen through the lens
of the knight
i like the move bishop f4 i think it
also nicely supports the knight on e5
and
also if you think of it this way look at
the bishop sort of skewering that pawn
on c7 i would say x-raying it so
something like knight c4 could come to
mind but
before we do anything i want to expand a
little bit on the queen side
let's let's grab a little bit of space
on the queen side
and open up the possibility for some
queen b5 ideas
now this queen on b6 is in a little bit
of trouble
what should we do how should we play
why did we play a4 we created a
stronghold on the b5 square
knight c4 would come close to trapping
the queen but queen c6
would be possible what can we put on b5
we could also go a5 but then we'd have
to reckon with queen takes b2
uh and i don't actually see a way to
trap the queen there so let's go knight
to b5
that's the reason why we played a4 we
established a nice little stronghold
and now the knight is pressuring the c7
pawn how are we going to exploit
and now we have an incredibly strong
move which is very important to find
we want to put the knight on c7 but we
can't do that
because he would take so we have to move
this knight away with tempo
no no if we play a5 we give up the
knight right pawn on a4 is fulfilling a
crucial role of defending the knight
so what we need to do is move this
knight away with tempo
so that the bishop combines with the
knight guards c7 and the move that does
that is knight to c4 very strong move
this move basically wins the game if he
plays queen a6
we trap his queen and deliver the fork
so he's gotta go queen d8
and he's gotta basically move his knight
away and say okay i'm down in exchange
the game goes on if the game is not over
when we win an exchange but
well he doesn't have any compensation
for it things are going to be very rough
for him
so we'll see how he manages to
defend this he can also okay knight to
d5 that's a very strong move
he actually found a move that i missed
and the purpose of this move
is that if we take on a8
then he takes on f4 and
our knight on a8 could get trapped
very strong move very strong we actually
have to back pedal here
we can play the queen e5 that's an
interesting move
yeah let's go queenie then he maybe goes
f6 or bishop f6
if we move our bishop away then he takes
the knight so we're gonna have to
backpedal
and take on d5 and sort of reorient
ourselves
let's centralize the other night this
happens i mean people are good
telling you guys people are good at this
level i actually missed that move
now this doesn't normally happen but you
know these people are underrated
let's support our center with the move
c3 i'm going to play a little bit faster
here because i'm a little bit low on
time
um and let's see what he does
yeah men can confirm rooks either this
guy is good we're just going to deploy
our pieces i'm not doing anything
extraordinary i'm just putting my pieces
on better squares
another thing i might consider here is
to play h3 uh just to create a little
bit of luft for our
king thank you james r for the sub
three months appreciate it okay
let's now deploy our queen to g4
threatening checkmate if he takes on e5
what piece should we take with here
should we take with the pawn or should
we take with the rook
yeah this opponent is playing very well
rook
absolutely the rook because we need to
keep open possibility we're rook lift
we need to keep the pressure going he's
playing well
we we need to drop our queen back to
defend the pawn on b2 now one idea that
we could have in this kind of position
is to push this h-bond forward and try
to provoke weaknesses in his position
okay f6 we're going to drop the rope but
now this pawn is weak where should we
put the stroke we should put it on e1
to attack the pawn let's not forget also
about the plan of going h5 h6
and provoking weaknesses in his position
okay um we should also yeah let's go
let's
let's
we can sack the spawn right because then
we're going to put a queen on h
on hx now we're going to move the rook
to f3 skewering his king
potentially preparing the move queen e5
he creates a very serious weakness where
is this queen going
it's going to g7 he's preventing that
threat we're going to defend b2 first
we're going to keep this queen nicely
centralized he's probably going to go
queen c7
if he plays like a gm which he probably
does
uh we're slowly starting to chip away at
his position but
yeah this guy is not 1500 okay
um we also could consider doubling or
tripling rather on the e-file
thank you lexic for the twitch prime but
he's good
he's good but that was that a mistake if
we take away let me calculate take
stakes
going to five rook f6 queen h7 yes we
have a beautiful sacrifice here let's go
we can crash through with rook takes f5
check if i calculated correctly queen
takes f5 and it's checkmate because
after oh
or is it yes it is where should we go
now
where should we go now this is the key
move it looks like he's covered against
all of the checks
but boom goes the dynamite queen takes
h7 and we go to e7 with checkmate
and that is game over red rover so
we got him in the end this guy's just
good let's let's give credit where
credit is due this guy is just good
and uh we we managed to outplay him
okay so i want to unpack that key moment
after he played knight d5 i know some
people are a little bit
confused at what happened there why did
i not take his rook
so let's talk about that briefly
okay so first of all
a little bit of chess history the scandi
was played the first time
that's pretty funny actually let's talk
some chess history
the scandinavian was first played in the
year
1475. i forgotten that now i remember
here's a piece of chess trivia i've
shared before as hojo jordan brings us
one step closer to that magic number
thank you for the prime
now chess is a very old game it's
existed for
several thousand years but
chess has not always existed with modern
rules and when chess came to europe
around the 13th 1400s
the first ever game of chess recorded in
modern history
played with modern rules was played
between i believe two spanish monks in
the year 1475.
and that game featured the scandinavian
mr vinolus
who played the first ever game of chess
recorded with modern rules thank you
admiral jones gifting to
uh fwip for the sox
was played with the scandy so was played
in 1475 and then after that in 1837
so there was about a 400 year gap
between the first time the scandinavian
was played
and then the second time it was played
uh which is kind of cool
in any case i just want us i want to
fast forward really quickly to the
moment
when he played this move knight c5 and
there's
i want to explain this and then i want
to share one very important piece of it
uh why is the scandinavian not good for
beginners
and openings like the scandi are not bad
per se
but in order to be able to play them
well you need to learn how to break the
rules
right because you're moving the queen
around in the opening thank you hojo
jordan
i really appreciate it you're moving
your queen around
and you need to okay i made the analogy
before to driving
so let's say you're learning how to
drive and
your instructor says and he puts you in
a bus
before you've ever learned how to drive
a car okay does that sound like a good
way of learning uh that has all these
added complexities
i actually quite admire people who drive
buses i can't imagine how that's
possible
but first you need to get the basics
down before you add these
twists and so openings like the scandi
or openings like the perk
you know they require you to to have
possession of all of these additional
controls
and in my opinion that can actually
sometimes curtail
the proper learning process so that's
why i
usually advise against these types of
openings
now the other thing to point out is in
this key position
we did not take on a8 why not
because knight takes f4 would have
followed
and if you guys will notice this knight
on a8 has no passage back
if you try to go queen e5 to evacuate
the knight via c7 actually black has
quite a beautiful move here
a nice little tactic that starts with
queen takes d4
and then picking the queen off and this
knight just seems to be dead meat after
knight a6
uh because that rook is just gonna go
around and capture it
and the thing is if you go to c7 it the
knight doesn't have any prospects from
there either
now you guys might look at this and say
hold on hold on how did you see this
how did you know well it's pattern
recognition because i've seen
other openings such as an opening called
the baltic
the baltic is a response to the queen's
gambit bishop f5
and in the baltic this occurs
very frequently if white falls into a
certain trap
he goes e3 allows knight b4 can somebody
tell me
what black should do in this position
somebody tell me what black should do in
this position well yes i'm down the
exchange there but you're gonna lose
another piece
one second guys
nope
queen take spawn boom
boom and you win a second game sorry
you win a second pawn by the way e3
would be also interesting trying to pave
the way for the knights of c2
but then the knight drops back to d3 i
would say e4
e5 is the best way to start
uh because then again you learn how to
follow the rules although i guess here
queen takes d4
so that would also be good but i wanted
to show the the sort of the
the influence of planner and recognition
on your thinking
and i used to fill up entire notebooks
with you know this kind of stuff you
know noting down these interesting
patterns
but what did we do in this game we said
okay
okay you got me i'm just gonna take on
d5
and white still has a perfectly fine
position so what i was going to tell
everybody is
if you meet with a move that you haven't
seen or you didn't see something
you don't want to lose your your cool
right you want to make the most out of
the situation
and if that means back pedaling and
admitting your mistake
and getting a normal position then
then that's what that that means but you
don't want to stubbornly go for
a strategy or a line that you know is
bad
uh you want to give yourself the maximum
amount of chances
and what did we do here we provoked a
bunch of weaknesses on his king side
and eventually that led up to a
sacrifice and checkmate
rook takes f5 is a move that you just
have to look at right
uh and you have to look at this move
because you ask yourself what is the
drawback of his previous move
whenever your opponent plays a move near
his king
with a pawn uh then you need to
immediately understand okay what
what impact did that make on his
position and it's clear to
anyone here that the pawn on f5 is now
not as well defended and so you got to
be optimistic right if you calculate
rook f5 you see that his king is out of
squares
by the way magnus carlsen i swear i saw
magnus carlsen game
where he um where he had a very similar
combination
he had a very similar combination if you
guys will give me a moment
this is a program called chess bass it's
a program that sort of all the gm's use
it was developed originally in the late
80s
uh it's pretty costly but if you're over
2000
i would say that uh it it it is a very
it's an indispensable tool for any gm
uh one thing that allows you to do is it
allows you to find
any game that you want it allows you to
search any position to see all of the
games that have been played from that
position
but i remember this game so this was a
karo khan and let me go to the important
moment magnus actually played a
brilliant game he sacrificed two pieces
in order to attack now he sacrifices a
rook
and he basically well i'm going to show
you guys the checkmate he lifts the rook
up and in this position he goes queen f5
check
rook f6 and now can somebody tell me
the final move of the game
what is the final move the game it's not
queen h7 queen h7 lets the king escape
via e6 it's queen to d7
and this is checkmate you guys see the
similarity
king on f7 sandwiched between the rooks
if we look at our game
well i would say it's pretty similar uh
so
i was thinking about that game as i was
delivering this mate i think there's
there's something distinctly
distinctly similar uh about this and so
yeah that's sort of how pattern
recognition works you see enough of
these games they're beat into your head
and you sort of you know that that
circles around in your mind